faith is a very potent force in the
world today the reason why faith is such
a potent force in the world today is
that religious world views are
continuing to be very important in the
lives of people religions are growing
numerically and religions are also
inserting themselves increasingly into
public realm sociologists talk about d
secularization of the world today and
this secularization means that the world
is not becoming more and more secular
indeed the world is becoming more and
more religious place more and more
people embrace faith and more and more
people think that fate should [ __ ]
should shape how they live in the world
today so we want to get a clear picture
as to the reach extensive reach of
faiths we want to also get a clearer
picture of the motivating forces for
fades inserting themselves into the
public realm we will approach this issue
by looking at case studies and one
important case study is comes from
united states and it is the star case
study of religious right now religious
fundamentalists in united states for
many years have thought that the
appropriate stands to where the world is
to retreat from it rather than engage it
and then in the 70s a transformation
happened what was a ghettoized religion
has suddenly become an engaged religion
indeed rather aggressively engaged
religion in the world today shaping the
way in which united states functions
both at the domestic and international
levels now that's a very interesting
transition that has happened and we want
to explore that tradition a similar
transition has happened also with what
one has described now is engaged
buddhism buddhism was in many ways a
religion that has also retreated in and
being in the privacy of people's lives
but in recent decades it
has increasingly become a public
religion hence the term engaged buddhism
now what makes a religion shift from
being privatized to being engaged what
makes a religion step onto the public
scene this these are the questions we
want to ask and these are the questions
we want to ask against the backdrop of
numerical growth of many religions in
the world today